Did they want to talk about,
uh,
the fall of France and then mostly about collaboration.
And next time I'm going,
I'm going to talk about,
uh,
about resistance.
Uh,
so the first part,
just,
just sort of a,
a briefly,
I mean,
looking back,
you know,
on,
uh,
you know,
I ended last time with or mentioned at the end of the hour last time that,
maybe 1936 was a time when Hitler could have been stopped in the Rhineland,
uh,
this,
all this business in the fall of France and the origins of World War One,
I have to be seen in,
in,
in the context of,
of you know,
of,
of World War One.
I mean,
there was a sense that if after the war there was this view that a wars were
started by evil people in high places and,
um,
who were doing evil deeds,
uh,
in,
in conjunction with,
with,
uh,
other people and Germany signed on the dotted line,
forced to do so saying they had been responsible for world war one.
And so there was a strong feeling that,
that the Wilson and others had that if you had an apparatus like the League of
late nations,
and if you had a so open covenance and that everything will be okay,
nobody would ever want to have another war again.
Well,
of course,
uh,
Hitler was determined from the very beginning to have a,
another war again.
And nobody had any illusions about that mine comp with available and all sorts
of languages,
including English.
Uh,
it's the book that he wrote,
my struggle,
which he wrote when he was in very comfy prison after the pooch pooch failed in,
in,
in Munich in the early 1920s.
And so,
uh,
I,
you know,
as possible to argue that,
that,
uh,
that France,
which had a whole series of,
of,
of rather inept,
uh,
leaders particularly in,
in,
in the 20s and early thirties,
not Leon Blooma wasn't enough at all,
but there was this feeling that,
that,
uh,
or they have another war,
wasn't,
wasn't thinkable.
Uh,
and,
um,
that,
that sort of lies in,
in,
in the background.
Now Hitler's preparation for war.
Um,
and the,
the construction of the building of the newest,
newest kind of weapons,
uh,
pushed them at,
gave them an advantage.
Hitler's generals were fairly sure that he would start the war in 1940 or 1941.
And the wars,
you know,
starts on the 1st of September,
uh,
1939 with the invasion of,
of Poland.
Now I'm just,
I mean,
militarily,
why did France fall so,
so,
so rapidly?
I mean,
you get a sense of this and Mark Block's book,
uh,
but the troop strength was almost equal,
at the,
at the beginning,
um,
uh,
of the war.
I mean,
after the phony war,
at the beginning of the invasion in 1940,
uh,
of France,
the Germans had 114 divisions.
Uh,
the French had 94 and the,
and the British had 10,
and then you have 20 to a Belgian divisions as well.
So,
uh,
it's about,
about even the number of,
of troop strength,
um,
in tanks,
uh,
the,
um,
the allies actually had superiority.
Um,
German tanks were lighter and we're faster.
And in the end that,
that and the way they were used,
uh,
used not just spread along the line,
but used in,
in tank and ponds or divisions,
uh,
gave,
gave the Germans and advantage and,
and the,
the French tanks had much more armor and therefore were heavier and couldn't be
maneuvered very rapidly,
but they,
they'd attached,
you know,
a number of tanks to each division.
They didn't use tanks as,
as really a,
as the kind of rapid use that,
that Hitler had tried out a,
uh,
on Poland.
Uh,
the Germans had a superior clear superiority in terms of,
of,
of air power,
particularly in light a bombers and in fighter bombers.
And these were used in Poland.
I mean,
they,
these been used in Spain.
So had they had tried these,
these weapons out,
um,
now how did the British and the French and planning for this war that came
along,
uh,
it,
they,
they believe that the war would be another kind of war of attrition.
And thus some wag once said.
And so it's,
it's,
it's tiresome.
How often has repeated that in 1914,
the friends who were prepared to fight the war of 1870 71,
and in 1939 and 1940,
they were prepared to fight the war of 1914 a.
And there's something to it.
Uh,
uh,
they thought that it would be a,
you know,
a long drawn out battle,
uh,
and which,
um,
uh,
that a,
a strong defensive line,
the no line,
uh,
those fortresses that were stretched along,
in Alsace and Lauren and an up in the,
in,
uh,
you know,
in the Moselle and other places that,
that,
that these would,
uh,
we would do the trick.
Um,
and that in the end that,
that the sort of of firepower of,
of cannons on defense would be much more important than the kind of rapid
movement,
whereas the Germans,
uh,
having already slaughtered the polls,
um,
who defended themselves rather hurt.
We're very heroically,
but,
but as you know,
you've seen him.
Sure.
Footage of it.
I'm a cavalry sometimes against tanks.
Uh,
they believed in,
in,
in rapid movement.
Uh,
and the word,
the term was the blitz creed.
You know,
that the rapid attack,
the,
the rapid movement.
Um,
and so one of the problems and all the planning of course,
is that the Mancino line,
uh,
stops at the Belgian border.
And so once again,
I mean,
you've got,
you've got hills and,
and uh,
and even small mountains in the are gone part of,
of Belgium and in the east.
And the French are assuming that,
that,
uh,
that the,
the Argonne forest and the owl then in,
in northern France and an eastern Belgium in northeastern France and in eastern
Belgium,
uh,
were impediments,
physical impediments that,
that,
that would not allow,
uh,
the Germans to,
to move through them.
Uh,
and,
and that's exactly what the,
what the Germans did,
uh,
with their,
with their tank,
uh,
you know,
with their tank,
uh,
columns.
And so,
um,
when 10 tank divisions pour into the owl,
then,
uh,
they'd simply waste the,
the,
these lighter a French tanks,
which hadn't been concentrated in any particular,
uh,
a way.
Uh,
and in four days,
the Germans crossed the Moose River,
uh,
and our way inside,
um,
France and,
and the,
and the German high command thought it would take nine days and the Germans
couldn't,
the French couldn't imagine that it was going to take nine days.
It takes four days.
And Hitler does make this one big mistake that allowed Dunkirk to happen.
You know,
the,
the withdrawal of so many British soldiers and,
and French soldiers is that,
that he,
he,
he stops the charge of the tanks.
Uh,
he refuels and this really allows the,
uh,
the evacuation at Dunkirk,
um,
uh,
to,
um,
to occur.
And so then,
I mean,
all of this sort of footage that you've seen of the,
of,
uh,
you know,
of,
of Belgian and French refugees and walking with everything they could push and
wagons or carry with them or put on there,
you know,
on their oxen or horse drawn carts or,
or in,
in automobiles are,
you know,
are fleeing the battle zones.
Just like the polls had tried to do a after the September 1st,
1939.
Uh,
and so it's just,
it's been repeated again.
It's happened again.
This hell is happened again.
And the difference was,
uh,
in 1940,
of course,
you've got the German fighter planes,
uh,
strafing,
these refugees and taking huge tolls of license or of picking them off as,
as they move anywhere they could move.
And once again,
southern France and central Francis is inundated with,
uh,
with people fleeing,
fleeing the battle.
Uh,
lots of Belgians ended up in our little village of,
you know,
which then only had about 250 people in it.
Uh,
um,
you know,
fleeing all of this.
And,
and once again,
another French government,
uh,
is,
they're on the verge of,
of,
uh,
of disaster.
And,
um,
the armistice is signed at Hitler's insistence in the,
in the railroad car.
It wasn't the same one,
but another railroad car in the forest of comb PN were,
were the Germans had signed on the 11th of November,
1918.
And you've all seen images of Hitler going off,
uh,
for the first time in his life to,
to,
uh,
Paris as a tourist and doing this little Jig that was filmed and,
and going to the,
uh,
Eiffel Tower and the architect can off and all of this business.
And,
uh,
and,
and that was that.
And of course,
uh,
the French now moving into this central part of the lecture,
um,
a new French government,
collaborates with the Germans and that government is known as Vichy France,
uh,
because,
Francis divided into two zones of that that is,
and you can read about this in ships,
this book,
but that,
that,
that is occupied by German troops,
essentially the north and the north part of France.
And then the,
the,
the so called free zone,
uh,
which,
um,
has his capital in the spa town of Vichy,
uh,
in,
in the Rda.
And the word collaboration,
the English word collaboration,
a word that you all know use to mean simply what one of the major meetings is
that,
that you know,
uh,
you collaborate with somebody.
If,
you know,
in a,
in a section you're supposed to,
you and someone else was supposed to put together a report on this or that,
or you do a lab report together.
Or in psychology,
people collaborate with eight other people.
And one of the problems as assessing folks work for promotion to see who's the
lead investigator.
You collaborate with people,
you collaborate with your brothers and sisters.
I'm trying to organize,
you know,
plans for the holidays and all that.
That was the use until 1941 1940,
41 until world war two.
It still is one of the uses.
And the term collaboration took on a less neutral meaning and collaboration
because of the experience of countries like France in world war two were in
every country.
Pete people actively helped the Nazis,
uh,
achieve their goals.
Uh,
so collaboration took on the sort of sinister term as well.
and the word in French and a Collabo,
uh,
is something with somebody who collaborated.
And by the end of 1943 and by early 1944,
if you were a French collaborator and you woke up one morning and you found a
graffiti with the K for coat for the German word,
for collaborator on your door,
uh,
you were toast.
Uh,
uh,
because it meant that the McKee were,
the resistors were,
were capable enough or confident enough to make that kind kind of threat.
So the word collaboration,
uh,
has taken this very,
very different meaning because of what happened.
And again,
it's not only France in Belgium,
Belgium,
still,
it's a very hotly contested issue because a Flemish,
we're more likely to collaborate right wing Flemish with the Germans.
Uh,
then walloons,
uh,
and in Hungary for example,
where you can go if you've been to Budapest,
my second favorite city,
uh,
where you see all those horrible shoe is not horrible shoes,
but I,
they were pulled out of the,
out of the Danube River af after Jews and communists were gunned down by a
Hungarian collaborators.
And we're left.
Now there's still there sort of cemented in this very small shoes to this
ghoulish memorial,
but one that has to be there.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
in these,
in these places or in Bulgaria,
uh,
the Germans didn't need to do lots of things because the,
there were people in every population that we're happy to be there,
better hit.
I mean to see them,
they're better Hitler.
Then bloom went the shouts in 1934,
35 and 36 and those shouts a continued,
of course in France.
Now the history,
history's have their history and,
uh,
there is none in modern French history,
more fascinating,
more,
uh,
Pos,
you know,
then,
uh,
the history of,
of,
of collaboration,
uh,
in France because even in my Jeunesse,
even when I was at was a kid,
uh,
the,
the sort of story was that it that did in France,
everybody resisted or almost everybody and hardly anybody collaborated.
And that was a myth that was perpetuated by,
uh,
people who had collaborated reactively,
very willingly,
very enthusiastically.
Uh,
and it was also a,
the myth that was perpetuated by Charles de Gaulle.
Uh,
because for Charles de Gaulle who assumed the kind of mammal of the resistance,
uh,
what he needed to do was to make people forget the communist resistance and,
and to see himself as for a mystical body of the French people that as his voice
crackled over the airwaves for those who could hear it.
And many people who hadn't heard it,
claimed to have heard it on the 18th of June in 1940 that we must keep a
resisting.
Uh,
it was part of,
of,
of the mantle that he would assume a on his shoulders before he stomped off the
column layout.
They do the uglies when he couldn't get his way in every issue after the war.
Uh,
it was,
but,
but part of,
of,
of the,
of the way that France would,
would put the new France with presented itself,
it had to be that almost everybody resisted and that only an elite,
uh,
collaborate it.
Um,
there was a movie from 1953,
1954,
uh,
a documentary in which it's about what happened to the Jews who were taken from
arrested in July,
1942,
a in the my,
the Jewish quarter of Paris.
And then the Youth San Louis and there were taken away.
And first they're put at a camp at draw,
see a transit camp,
which is north of Paris in Tennessee.
And the place was called festival in a,
or something like investor Balkan in the transit camp in,
uh,
in the Netherlands and,
and,
and Macklin or marine.
Uh,
in Belgium.
I have a student who's working on it,
uh,
a topic now,
but in the film and the original film,
it's a documentary.
You could see French guards,
John Dorm,
they're guarding the Jews who were there.
And of course,
when the film was published,
you couldn't have a friend,
Sean Dharm guarding the Jews.
They had to be guarded by,
by Nazis,
didn't they?
So what they did is they took the soldier out of the film,
they lifted right out of the film.
So he's not in the film.
He disappears from the film.
Uh,
and um,
until the late 1960s,
this myth of,
of,
uh,
that everybody had resisted or almost everybody,
only elites had collaborated Petain and his inner circle was the dominant kind
of myth.
And now since then we've had what has been called in a very wonderful book by
Audrey was so no book,
this translated in English,
the Vichy Syndrome.
Now Vishi of people,
uh,
you know,
who didn't live through the two fee sheet,
but they're trying to find out what happened and to kind of crucial events of
three kind of crucial events caused people this collective memory,
a desire to know what really happened during this time.
And they're three events that were,
or series of events that happen.
Um,
one was,
uh,
probably I guess you could say,
and this is what the Russo and others have argued that there was a film called
the sorrow and the pity a,
which goes on and on.
It's four and a half hours.
I used to show it in this class.
I think I described this once in here.
Uh,
uh,
the,
it was,
had a reputation for being a two,
six pack film because it was so late,
so long.
And we would show it and Wla h and at the end,
this is when the drinking age was 18.
And I assure you,
uh,
you know,
there'd be all sorts of beer bottle.
It's just all over the place.
It was so long and it's,
the sound quality isn't very good,
but it's,
it's,
it's a very important because what the,
what the,
the,
the or Foose who was a producer did,
is he went to one single town,
he went to Claremont fail,
you know,
Vannia and,
and he looked at,
at,
and what happened there at collaboration.
And some of the great scenes in documentary history are there when,
uh,
of,
of the intentional for repression or forgetting when the two teachers,
if you've seen the film,
you know,
they forget about their Jewish colleague.
Uh,
there's amazing things at the end,
you know,
when they shave the heads of what they called,
rather crudely horizontal collaborators,
women who had slept with German soldiers.
And at the end of the war,
there's these scenes where they shave their heads and haul them to the streets,
not just in criminal federal.
And at the end there is,
there is,
I think I said this the first day,
but there is a Malisa Chavela da who was a sort of Shawnta are there sort of
crooner of your grandparents' generation who became the famous French person in
the u s with his excellent.
And like that.
Then at the very end of the film,
he says,
well,
you know,
uh,
he says,
you know,
there are these stories that I was seeing in Germany,
but I want to tell you,
I was only seeing four z boys.
That is the,
the people who had gone off and been been,
uh,
who had been captured in the fighting or who had gone and,
and,
and had to go into obligatory service.
I'll tell you about work service had gone to Germany.
Many of them died in the [inaudible],
in the air raids.
And at the end,
you know,
we'd wearing his white suit and his straw hat and,
and,
and uh,
for getting his own very public in origins in,
in,
in my mouth.
He says,
for the Americans,
we're going to see the film,
but I want to assure you that I only thing for z boys.
And of course it was not the case at all.
Uh,
but this,
what this movie does is,
is it?
And it was only shown in one theater.
I in the Ma,
hey,
appropriately enough,
I saw it,
uh,
you know,
a couple of years after it came out,
it was still in the same single theater.
It was made for French TV.
It was never shown on French TV until 1980,
1981 or 1982 never on French TV.
Never,
never,
never.
Why?
Because it told the awful truth is that lots of people believe better Hitler
than bloom.
And many people got an a plateau handed to them by the outcome of this war,
of this,
this short war,
the kind of regime that they wanted.
What did they want?
Well,
I'll talk more about that in a minute.
The second kind of event that happened is,
uh,
this makes me feel old.
I is that my friend Bob Paxton,
who is much older than me,
uh,
that he wrote a book,
called,
uh,
Vichy France that was published in English,
in 1972 and often say in probably 73.
Um,
and Vichy France was about,
uh,
it took off.
It took off the Uhh,
it to cut through this sort of intentional forgetting of what had happened to
look at as collaboration to look at collaboration.
Now,
Bob Paxton did not have the right to use French documents.
Why archival documents?
The kind that I use studying earlier periods.
Why?
Because there's a 50 year role.
Uh,
also because even when he was writing on a guy called Giorgio has,
who was sort of a,
a authoritarian,
um,
crypto fascist,
uh,
in who had a lot of influence in the send the,
a mount and allowed to share and a lot of departments near Paris.
He was called a troublemaker by an archivist because he tried to get documents
that would have implicated lots of very powerful families and in strike
breaking.
And that's kind of stuff in the,
in the 1930s,
but when this book came out,
it had a major kind of effect and it was followed by book that he did with
Michael Merritts called Vichy and the Jews,
uh,
a story that I will tell just in part later,
and this had a huge effect because suddenly here was this American American
historian,
a greatest story and saying it wasn't like you learned in school,
it wasn't like that.
And I remember my wife and I were in Roussel at once and we were in a hotel in
Brussels,
in Brussels and,
and um,
there was this inevitable,
so French show,
they bring in those six or seven different people and there was an,
and there was a pit,
there were skinhead fascist picketers picketing the Paxton's presence in this
show.
And at one point,
you know,
it's one of the typical French things where they're bringing in somebody who had
lived through the war,
somebody who had read something about the war,
uh,
you know,
and all of that.
It was just the tip of the Mesh.
MSMB do,
but,
or this is thing,
they kind of throw it together.
But at one point this guy gets up and he said,
what do you,
could you tell us about the war?
You were,
you didn't know you were only 12 years old then during World War II or whatever
Bob was.
But this book had an enormous impact and the power of this book and of this man,
he was the one to introduce it.
That's all been,
uh,
as the conscience of France.
Mr Pack's that packs and don't assign a certain sauce of who said [inaudible].
That's pretty heavy stuff by [inaudible] who is a historian.
Uh,
and third really are the trials,
the trials.
Uh,
and,
uh,
as,
as collaboration came to be something that people wanted to know about what
happened to the Jews,
what happened to the people that were arrested because they were communists,
who were they arrested by the Germans and we're happy to do it,
but there and rested by the French.
Then they started tracking down people with rather bad histories.
And one of the first was a man named [inaudible] [inaudible],
v I.
E r and to Va,
uh,
was involved in lots of bad things.
The torture of,
of resistors.
Uh,
uh,
the arrest of and deportation,
the certain death of,
of Jews,
communists and people like that.
And to VA was hidden by right wing Catholic groups.
They're called antique niece in French.
Um,
the role of the church in all of this,
I,
I better get to in a while.
Um,
and he was hitting,
he was bounced from monastery to monastery in the oatmeal,
a team above a niece and up in the outdoors privas I,
and he was hidden and they finally tracked the guy down and they put him on
trial and he was condemned.
And at this trial and at others,
Paxton became what they call a team wa x bear,
an expert witness.
Now that's very important in,
in French law.
If you,
you know,
you have a lawsuit against somebody who screwed up your house or your apartment
for bad work,
you know,
they always bring in witnesses who are experts in carpentry to say that they
screwed up or they didn't screw up at what point they screwed up,
et cetera.
But here you've got historians and the story and have a much greater public
role,
uh,
in,
in France and then the u s I mean people care about history much more than they
do in the u s and so Paxton became this expert witness in the trial of two VA
and then the trial will Klaus,
clause B Bar Bie,
uh,
who had a close bow,
had tortured people in Leone and to close,
Bobby was in,
had a lot of authority when Mark Block,
when he was,
uh,
set up and arrested on a bridge or a a that goes over the song and tortured a
hideously north of the,
on a place called colonial Honda.
Ah,
uh,
and cluck,
cluck,
Klaus Barbie was put on trial,
was brought back and,
and Paxton was an expert witness there too.
But IB was confronted literally with,
with now very old ladies that he had tortured himself in,
in,
uh,
you know,
during the war.
I mean,
torture is not a good thing.
The Americans do it too now.
And that's not a good thing,
but that's another subject.
Americans didn't use to do things like that,
but they do things now like that now.
Uh,
but pacsun would,
would,
you know,
was an expert witness in this.
And then there was Popol Merissa pop pump and you're old enough to maybe even an
oak.
We is Maurice Pop.
Paul,
uh,
was,
it works in the prefecture in the [inaudible] in Volvo.
And he was a functionary and Reese,
uh,
pop.
Paul,
uh,
signed the death certificates essentially,
of,
of all hundreds and hundreds of Jews who were taken to the Golf Sanjay Hall and
Boldo,
and then were transported toward the death camps in Auschwitz and the others.
Actually,
I,
it was enough,
Sasa German set up and,
and,
uh,
to Blanca and,
and,
uh,
dot.
Kao and all these,
these infamous death camps.
Um,
and he went on to a very successful career,
uh,
in the fourth and fifth republic.
A very,
uh,
you know,
kind of important bureaucrat.
And,
and they caught up to this very old man.
Do you put really old people on trial?
We'll put,
p town was on trial after the war and they allowed him to,
uh,
to die on a small island off the coast of the,
of a,
of the von day or the Atlantic island.
Um,
and,
um,
there was even a big uproar about 15 years ago when there was a rope Voltaggio.
There was a documentary,
they had very use of Nice music and you saw the old man penning his letters,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And there are various attempts to steal his bones and bury them in Vail.
Done.
I mean,
so,
but all of this,
the Vichy syndrome,
his obsession with Vichy,
uh,
was accentuated by these trials.
And so when Risa pop poem with put on trial in 1998 and 1999 and at one point he
escapes,
he was under house arrest and he escapes and they arrest him in a fine
restaurant in Switzerland,
which is where he'd gone to it,
you know,
with his friends to try to escape the trial.
And then the question of what do you do with them?
He was kind,
he said,
but what he said is,
I was a good bureaucrat.
He said my,
uh,
my,
supervisors,
uh,
where my superiors were,
we thought it was excellent.
And he used that famous argument that Paxton in his book Vichy France demolished
that is the shield argument.
That is if it wasn't,
uh,
and this is the thing that the people defending Petain use to that.
If it wasn't for me,
if it wasn't for we,
he always used the royal we pay town,
uh,
then things wouldn't be even worse.
And Pat Paul said,
well,
you know,
if I hadn't signed this,
this,
I was supposed to sign certificates.
We were supposed to find out who were Jews.
And if I hadn't signed,
uh,
you know,
if I,
I only signed,
you know,
400 out of the 600 or whatever,
well,
you know,
an impulse to Coopa.
But I mean,
it just,
the w was a pathetic,
and then he was,
he was found guilty.
I am.
And then they put him in,
in jail under very nice conditions for awhile.
And then he had gotten very sick.
He just died within the last year.
And I think he's,
you know,
90 years was 90 or something like that.
Yep.
But these trials were sorted.
The third aspect or the third,
you know,
a key moments or three of the key moments in France coming to grips with,
um,
with,
with collaboration that not everybody resisted.
And it wasn't just elites who collaborate.
By the way,
there was another guy who was going to go on trial,
uh,
a guy called [inaudible],
who was the head of,
um,
uh,
he,
he was,
uh,
it had,
one of the heads of the police in Paris,
uh,
during,
during Vishi.
And he was supposed to go on trial,
but he was murdered by this,
this crazy guy who thought by killing him,
he'd give it publicity to was his own book.
He'd written the sort of bad and book.
And so he went to,
uh,
busquets apartment and guns them down before he could go on trial.
So unfortunately Bruce Gay and everyone on trial.
But so from having no official memory of Vichy,
no,
the only,
you know,
sites of memory they had to do with the resistance,
which was,
I'm going to talk about next time,
uh,
that sense,
you know,
before you were born,
but France underwent this,
this reevaluation and that was important for people who had lost family members
because of Vichy.
Uh,
it was important for,
uh,
for Jews,
some 75,000 Jews never came back to France.
They tried,
of course,
at the beginning to end this,
if they did this in Bulgaria to end in Hungary,
they had first you'll rest the foreign Jews,
not assimilated Jews.
So the big roundup in July of 1842 and 1942,
the hospitalist,
the French word half,
I mean the sort of sweep in the mouth,
hey and in,
in,
in a,
and you'll,
San Louie was not done by the Germans who have been very happy to do it.
You know,
they didn't care,
they'd do it.
It was done by the French.
It was done by the French police.
And really,
and one of the worst institutions is of course the Middle East,
the militia,
the militia mil.
I CE the militia who are created in January,
1943,
uh,
to get tough on the Jews get tough on the resisters,
get tough on the,
on the Communist.
And these were some of the worst of the collaborators in the pop home trial.
It came out there.
They interviewed various people who had been in,
were very old by then.
You know,
obviously who had been in,
in,
in prisoned,
in um,
uh,
in,
in Boldo around Boldo.
And they,
I actually brought some German soldiers back there too.
And one of them testified,
I remember this,
uh,
he said if we,
if we had a guy on guy,
you know,
a guy who we picked up in a suite and he was a resistor,
our,
he was a communist or something like that.
If we kind of liked the guy,
uh,
you know,
and you get on with them after a couple of days when you're guarding them and
you find things in common that you have the often,
that wasn't the case,
that if we wanted to save him from hideous torture,
we didn't give them to the French militia because of what they would do.
But of course,
by 1943 more about this later,
but there was a case in Eros where this woman who had denounced a couple of
resistors and she,
uh,
had,
um,
was an open collaborator and she was,
uh,
she lived up in the northern part of l Dash A.
Uh,
and she walked across the bridge across the road one day to go shopping and the
other side of the river and the diploma and a pebble came up behind her and put
a bullet right through her head and blew her head off.
Uh,
you know,
collaborators had to really decide what,
what there were up to.
And of course,
a lot of them,
uh,
something like 10,000 were executed almost immediately in the days after the
war.
But for people,
uh,
maybe I mentioned this the first day when I was trying to tell you about one of
the things we do,
but for people like my friend who,
um,
uh,
he couldn't remember,
but his brother,
uh,
could remember the day that the Germans,
the Germans in this case came into a French suburb place called Lupa,
who's through mound and took his father who was part Jewish,
who was Greek and took him away.
Then the Nazis came to get him and he was denounced by a French policeman for
being Jewish.
And letters of NCH can roll over the place.
And you wrote a letter of denunciation.
You know,
those are big costs.
You're not saying,
you know,
so-and-so's watering their lawn too much as they're doing in Atlanta,
which is,
you know,
it's a bad thing to water lawn.
But there was this real Paul Taj,
I saw it the other day about everybody turning in their neighbors because
they're watering your lawn,
but you write something to the French malicious things.
Someone's as a Jew,
you know,
you're selling out,
you're selling their life away or so and so's of communist or so and so's a
resistor.
And,
uh,
the whole,
um,
and for this guy who was father was taken away with a wife after the war
everyday when she will,
every Saturday when she went to the market,
she saw the same policeman directing traffic there who had denounced her husband
who is responsible in a personal way,
not this sort of indirect way,
uh,
a personal way for,
for her,
um,
the death of her husband.
And for people like that,
there was a sort of a satisfaction that you can,
well,
imagine,
even if you're not somebody like,
you know,
somebody of a vengeance.
I mean,
I would have gone and spent years tracking these people down.
Um,
but you know,
she wasn't like that.
Uh,
but there'll be a moment of vindication when,
when the textbooks begin to change.
That's something too.
And then my kids were in seg on than in France and the textbooks are really,
now they're starting to,
to change,
uh,
you know,
change about the way the whole period was covered.
But that's something that comes out of this.
So histories have their histories,
uh,
as,
um,
you know,
as well.
And the next history,
by the way,
and not to sort of leap ahead,
that will be,
it was sort of unveiled.
Um,
we'll be of course,
uh,
the Algerian war and all that.
Uh,
and same kind of talk shows that they're beginning day that they've had now for
the last 15 years on French TV all the time.
The documentaries they never would have shown before.
We'll start to happen about the Algerian war and also for those generations
passing away,
you know,
it's important for them to talk about these things and you're not in the
situation as I described.
In the case of World War One was only one single,
uh,
former soldier who wasn't,
where a one is still alive in Britain.
Uh,
you know,
if you saw the Ken Burns thing about World War II,
I mean they did a lot of interviews with people.
Now they're 84,
85,
86 [inaudible] 82 extraordinarily lucid.
So there's lots more that can be done.
Now,
what did the people who collaborated what,
first of all,
just a moment,
the beginning of two things at the beginning.
Um,
whereas in voting left in France,
you could do a map of and place a map on that and place it on a map of d
Christianization and the French revolution and the elections of 1849 and I've
said this before and it'd be remarkable,
a remarkable similarity in hardly any changes at all.
That's not true in terms of collaboration,
uh,
north,
that true in resistance.
Um,
collaboraters didn't come from one certain region as opposed to another,
which is largely the case in Belgium.
Uh,
uh,
there were collaborators everywhere.
They don't come from one social class either.
Um,
now in one of the,
the,
the haunting images of,
um,
in this film and Star on the piteous,
there's a guy called Christiana that who,
you know,
noble vintage and he's in or he's interviewed in a smoking,
the sort of smoking jacket.
Uh,
and he in his chateau and he's very bright.
He's very articulate and he describes why he liked,
you know,
why he was happy to go and fight along the Nazi soldiers in the east and what
was called the Waffen ss.
You know,
these divisions,
I mean,
he 80,
so articulate and you think,
how can a smart guy like that ever do these things?
How can he hate Jews?
How can you want to see them die?
How can he see,
want to see communists,
you know,
gun put up against the wall and gun down,
working class guys from the na or peasants from,
from the Ole Vannia.
And he explains it.
Now you're more apt to have upper class people collaborate.
Just as in the traction of national socialism in Germany is the middle classes
that go that way first.
And this true in France in the 19,
1930s as well.
But you know,
you can't make any,
any,
uh,
there are working class people collaborate as well.
You can't make any of these kinds of generalizations.
What about religion?
Now the role of the pope in all of this is,
is,
is nauseated.
The pope knew he did nothing.
He did zero Z oh nothing.
And they knew,
he knew when the mayor,
when Roosevelt,
and these people knew also is that,
you know,
they knew earlier and they did think about it.
There's various reason they didn't bomb the death camps.
But if you bomb the death camps and you're killing a lot of people in the death
camps and all of that,
it's,
you know,
it's not so easy.
But the Catholic church,
the church hierarchy generally was extremely collaborationist because,
uh,
but the bishop of Toulouse Lewis was a very heroic guy who in his sermons would
say,
leave these people alone.
And the Bishop of [inaudible],
which is about 45 minutes drive away,
uh,
to the northeast,
was,
uh,
you know,
Anne Torres collaborator also,
I'll talk more about priests.
Uh,
Eh,
uh,
you know,
priests are,
are our community leaders in many parts of France.
Some of them were happy to see,
uh,
the Germans come,
and some of them were not and some,
some of them were collaborators.
Uh,
and some of them didn't.
And some of them got there is after the war,
there was a priest in a village near,
near us and he had had day I who was a notorious fascist,
uh,
into,
you know,
this sort of public reception and all that.
And 1944 August up against the wall,
you can still see the bullet holes there where they gunned him down.
People who collaborated village nearly most,
um,
or I spend a lot of time and [inaudible] has a place called a wears it as a bike
guy from uh,
uh,
[inaudible] and [inaudible] 1944 August,
they're partying.
Someone says,
where's the John Down this soul,
these people away.
Where is he?
He's got an an in,
in,
um,
in limos.
A friend of mine and former Guy I knew from the archives of Gal at the end when
he was my friend,
he was my companion will,
uh,
is he would call me.
Um,
they,
and he saw this cause he was a refugee from Lauren and somebody said,
where's the guy?
The guy's in a f guy is in there.
He's in these,
in Lemoshe.
So they stopped partying,
they walked to the Moje,
nobody had cars or gas.
They go to the aunt's house,
he's there fam,
and they put them at the head of this procession,
a cottage,
and they're all shouting and singing and they,
before they're going to party,
put them against the wall like that in this end of that.
So these things,
you know,
evoke very strong memories for these people.
But the church's role of the church got what it wanted.
And in many ways,
no divorce there.
Two people executed for abortion.
Actually,
uh,
only two,
but still,
that's a lot for,
uh,
for uh,
practicing abortion,
um,
nor divorce,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
but you know,
it's,
that's not the only story.
There were people who moved from the Catholic left into the resistance,
uh,
as many of them joined the Communist Party subsequently.
But anyway,
it's not,
it's not that opening shot.
Um,
but what,
what are these people,
what are these people want?
Who are collaborates?
Here's a couple of themes,
bunch of themes.
Um,
first of all,
the argument that [inaudible] made after the war,
um,
was that again,
it's the shield argument is that by collaborating with the Germans,
uh,
you are preserving the French state.
But as Paxton said it with amazing eloquence,
he said they may have stayed the same,
the French state,
but they destroyed the French nation.
What does the French nation mean?
Liberty,
you turn a quality fraternity,
not pottery,
you know,
and work and all that,
God a et Cetera that they put on the coins during Vishi.
Uh,
but they would say we are,
we are maintaining the innocence of the independence of France and in,
and the innocence that was the right slip there,
the innocence of France.
Because the view had to be that we were martyred by the loss of Udl of autonomy.
And we'll get it back by doing what the Germans want by helping them rebuild
economically.
The Germans wanted to take,
you know,
industrial convert it to war use and that kind of thing.
We'll do what they want.
So that's one theme.
But the shield argument has pretty much been,
uh,
been denounced.
Second,
um,
xenophobia that the xenophobia of that,
that characterize the French right.
And the 1920s in the 1930s,
the racism and xenophobia became state policy.
The foreign Jews were shipped off,
but also lots of quote unquote French Jews.
I'm not making that differentiation.
This is one that,
that they made.
Uh,
and um,
you know,
I think there's a hotel called [inaudible],
which is a very fancy hotel.
A several by being on that was a place where key people came after the war.
When Jews came back,
if you made it back,
you went there,
you went there every damn day to see if somebody from your family who was coming
back.
And most of them didn't come back.
Most of them didn't come back.
But to xenophobia was no Italians,
no Spanish,
especially communists.
Again,
the fear,
the fear of Marxism,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
they put the Spanish refugees in camps.
the,
the republic had the Popular Front had at the end of the Popular Front and camps
up in the Pyrenees or gentile,
you know,
uh,
between pappy and on the see places like ours,
gls and all of that.
Uh,
they,
that was what was given to them on the plateau on the platter is to make a
xenophobia part of state policy.
Third,
and this is a subset,
but it should stand by itself as antisemitism that the French Vichy regime.
And let me interject the fact that it's only in the Vember of 1942 that the
Germans occupied the Vichy zone.
Cause because the resistance is,
is mobilizing,
um,
that,
uh,
the French put in laws about Jews depriving Jews of rights that the Germans
didn't even ask them to do.
And in terms of of saying,
well,
if you were Jewish,
cause your grandmother or your grandfather was Jewish too,
I don't remember exactly the loss,
but the,
but the laws in some ways,
or even harsher than the famous infamous Nuremberg laws of,
uh,
of the hike they put in,
even harsher laws.
And they did it because they wanted to,
not because the Germans were saying,
you do this better Hitler then bloom.
And that's the way that fee she wanted it.
That's the way that Vichy wanted it.
And,
and as the Jews disappeared,
as they disappeared to Dossie and these other places,
uh,
how many preset,
and again,
I'm not being provocative and I went to,
I went to a Jesuit school for better for worse,
there go the Christ killers there,
they go in the little trains bouncing along off to draw c and then off to the
camp.
So antisemitism becomes official policy.
Pay Town was a notorious anti-semite.
The high command of the French army was,
was replete with antisemitism had always been that way.
Alfred Dreyfus was better than one Jew,
perish or die in Devil's island.
And it was at the army,
be a,
that it's honor,
be compromised.
That's the way they viewed it as they're supported by the assumptionist and all
these other people.
Uh,
so that,
that's important,
uh,
point,
as well.
But there are other themes to that.
If you read things that,
that,
that they wrote at the time that the collaborators road who read the
proclamations of pay tab,
uh,
if you read the,
the,
the kind of a spin,
they didn't call it that,
then,
uh,
around the Marshall who was always supposed to be described as walking with a
sprightly step was rather like when they were trying to describe Reagan.
And,
uh,
you know,
who the Animus,
his reign was totally out of it.
And,
and,
and the end of their always treat soy supposed to be described or not comparing
Reagan to pay town.
Uh,
but,
but you know,
you're talking,
we were very old people.
Uh,
but,
uh,
he's always supposed to be described in a way that it,
he is his personal,
his body is his being represents what the right considered to be wrong with
France.
That he was a dictator.
He's an authoritarian,
finished the France of air,
Aperitif,
finished the France of,
of quarrelling,
uh,
fragments or factions in the,
in the Shawmanee deputy.
And so I'm about,
by the way,
the fascist,
the role of the actual fascists.
Uh,
it's,
it's rather similar to what happened in Spain,
but I don't have time to do this now,
but the philosophy in Spain where the real fascist and they're kind of kept at
an arm's length by,
by,
uh,
by Franco,
the real fascists in all of this,
not the authoritarian right ones,
but they share a lot in common.
All the teams I'm talking about,
we're sharing to both of them,
but they were kind of kept them at arm's length in,
in Paris and this kind of stuff.
But anyway,
the decadence that I'm Vichy is going to be an answered a decadents,
a junior la Rochelle said,
I am a fascist because I have measured the progress of decadence in Europe.
And I mean,
I believe that I've seen the fascism as the only means of liberating and
reducing decadents.
Uh,
and that this is a term that,
that,
that comp cams up open over and over again.
Second,
the church,
I've already said that,
but,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
give France,
they're all sorts of conversions of the,
of the prayer.
Our Father in the Catholic church,
I don't know if there's a process church just to whatever our father who art in
heaven,
all that,
um,
you know,
uh,
on earth so that we may live,
give us our day,
our daily bread,
give,
give France back her life,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
That the answer to the,
to the decadence of France,
it's going to be refined.
Those old Christian Catholic values associated with Joan of arc.
By the way,
there's a revival of fanaticism about,
about Joan of arc,
uh,
and,
and this,
this is an important part of,
of the whole thing.
Then it will be returned to moral order.
Remember the government of the moral order of the early of the 1920 then the
1870s.
It's a return to moral order when things are passed down from moral authorities
represented by the church in conjunction with,
uh,
with pay tax.
So it's sort of like in a monarchy really.
Uh,
but,
but so the role of religion and of church and all of this is going to be
important.
The boy scouts,
for example,
a scouting,
uh,
has always had very close ties and France to,
to,
uh,
to the Catholic church.
And it's still a very controversial there.
Uh,
now,
um,
third I mean nationalism that if you'd just been blown away in yet another,
uh,
not yet another net world war one.
It was not a rapid defeat.
It was a victory long victory.
But as an 18,
70,
71,
uh,
that Frances independence is that of a nation whose image has been transformed
away from Liberty Fraternity,
equality hell with all of that,
from their point of view into this work of world of order and work and Paci
religion.
[inaudible]
goes on,
on,
on the,
uh,
on the coins.
And in doing that and saying that,
uh,
this nationalism becomes one that is exclusionary,
that is,
that's one of the characteristics of these right wing movements all over Europe.
I Hitler says,
uh,
with a mayor of Vienna said,
and you know,
I just decide who's a Jew.
This is,
you know,
in the 1890s,
uh,
Hitler says,
we will determine who's a Jew and then we will kill them.
And then,
uh,
the pay town was very happy to see the Jews go.
Couldn't,
he could have cared less pay Tassie hero avail know.
And so there's no room in the all,
uh,
of not of,
of the republic,
but of the Marshall for Jews.
That's part of the nationalist method of a message and method,
uh,
of,
of this.
It's there next,
um,
well,
authority,
authority comes top down.
I'm kind of repeating,
but,
but you get the point.
Authority comes from top down.
It doesn't come from people elected to represent the,
the,
the Ode.
Gahan,
you know,
to lose his region,
uh,
in the [inaudible] sitting in the Polyvore ball in the political club.
It could authority comes from the top down.
This is the 1920s,
thirties and forties.
And that's what they viewed as a very good thing.
Next peasant TISM that true France is what they called it.
True France,
the real France,
not the France of Jews,
not the France of,
of growth of graph.
No strikes,
strikes are illegal.
Not that,
not the strikes of,
of,
I mean not the France of working class organizations.
No stage Aytay organize workers need not apply,
need not exist,
uh,
a et Cetera,
et cetera.
That,
and all of this,
uh,
virtue is found in,
in the,
in the soil and just Joan of arc,
who's a peasant girl from my bed to her house or what they claim as our house
in,
in the,
in the moods and the,
in the east of France.
She becomes a symbol of,
of not only of sort of this nationalism,
you know,
chasing away the Brits and all of this before she's burning her wall,
but are they English that weren't British then?
Uh,
but,
but becomes the virtue in herself of,
of,
of being attached to the soil.
Uh,
that cities are places where Jews hangout,
cities or places we'll organize workers hang out and that the true France is
that,
uh,
of peasants and the soil.
And so these groups that like the Shawl,
where did I write it up here somewhere?
The Sean ta,
uh,
del [inaudible],
which are the sort of work shops or work areas of youth where they're supposed
to get up early in the morning,
you know,
instead of of smoking a pack of Gum,
Gallo was before noon is supposed to get up,
which is a terrible thing.
I just wanted to get up and not drink alcohol at 1130,
but as supposed to,
you know,
maybe go running a little than claps reasoning along and then jump into some
pond like the Nazis did.
It was,
we're supposed to do that.
And the Pomeranian frozen Pomeranian lakes,
uh,
that this is this,
this is learning about the true France,
which is this,
this,
you're going to,
you're going to the decline of France,
uh,
is going to be putting people back on the soil,
putting him into work and all that.
And then,
then there's finally,
and I'm going to have to stop,
but I'm,
I'm basically done.
Or there was this corporatism which was mostly just window dressing.
It's a corporatism they'd read,
they'd read,
uh,
something about Italian fascism.
And Mussolini tries to organize a industries hierarchy.
Clay making the argument that workers in bosses who are in say metallurgical
production and have the same interest,
which of course is ridiculous,
but if you're organized things corporately speaking,
you won't have strikes cause there are illegal.
And then if you get people to buy into the nation the way that many German
workers did,
but not all,
uh,
then you will solve your social problems.
We won't have anybody.
Everybody will get up and,
and be chanting,
uh,
singing,
saying their prayers in the morning on their knees and schools that the Marianne
has gone from the walls.
The crucifixes are there.
Uh,
and uh,
you will have this,
a happy vision,
one that the good fortune as they believe in it,
of Francis,
uh,
the decadent Francis defeat by these all these strong marching to tonic
warriors,
uh,
had,
given Cha France,
the,
uh,
the possibility of creating this brave new world without communists,
without Jews,
without gays,
uh,
without abortion,
without strikes,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But it didn't work out that way happily.
And by a,
as I said,
by the end of 1943,
if you woke up and you saw a k that written on your door,
you better get your tooth brush and get ready to move because things began to
change and why it began to change.
And the origins of the resistance and who resisted is a fascinating topic.
And that's the one we're going to do next Monday.
I'm going to a New Mexico between then and now,
but I will see you on Monday.